et bien bonjour et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo de type fonds vert de keats est
pas ma caméra et de type c'est pas mon
micro qui même posé sur une poubelle
donc aujourd'hui je suis sur la chaîne
de juliette très alignions va vous dire
avec juliette des mensonges et des
vérités deux choses rêve pour une
anecdote fausse chacun des achats que
vous allez devoir déterminer quel est le
mensonge de juliette décalé - mensonges
sur la chaîne vous avez toutes les
ressources possibles et inimaginables
pour déterminer sa il va y avoir
d'ailleurs quelqu'un d'autre qui l'a
cherchée en direct qui va aussi nous
poser des questions comme ça ça va vous
donner des indices en la personne de
william alias doc savage deux anecdotes
veille royal et d'autres fois tu peux
nous poser toutes les questions que tu
veux juste ne nous donnera pas des
conclusions finales
ok tu lui donneras plus tard parce que
on fera la révélation de nos mensonges
dans une vidéo qu'on va tourner sur pas
cher tu t'es très animé c'est ça pense
qu'il faut commencer en juillet après ce
qui peut s'avérer moins à l'aise
toc toc mais toi tu sais pas ce qui
m'est difficile à lire donc aux
tentations
[Musique]
bien tenté attendant très mal j'ai
montré très mal et je suis derrière tout
rouge où on peut faire un truc contre ça
les palpitations elle est faite de décès
n'ont atteint maintenant je peux le dire
donc ça va je suis enceinte bah quoi le
dialogue auquel moi j'ai comme un des
pilotes j'ai mis quelqu'un de très
proche en simple alors ma première
anecdote c'est que ma première anecdote
attention au temps de la montée c'est
que c'était tout simplement pour la
première fois j'ai fait dans une
émission de télé tout un truc sur la
mémoire durant 30 minutes j'ai parlé la
mémoire et la toute fin m'a demandé
faire la promo de mon spectacle à
l'olympia qu on m'a dit comment il
s'appelle de ce texte à blainville album
de 72,18 réservés j'ai pas retrouver le
nom de mon propre spectacle mais
vraiment on est obligé de couper j'ai
été obligé d'aller voir sur internet
pour ne rappeler comment s'appelait
montrées très déçues tendance
voilà des questions pas quand je veux
moi qu'est la bafin d'accord le premier
speech on dit encore stif a demandé à
juneau le 1er juin que j'ai filmé en
c'est ça c'était avec tina turner c'est
son mari qui l'a coupé la route
c'était à côté de cahors la kayak
pendant un instant dans le lot tout le
monde y plus vifs toi qui dit quoi
l'argent je suis à 1 dimanche qui a dit
du contenu licite du contenu illicite
ça m'est arrivé qu'une fois tu t'es de
la drogue grâce à toi ma vidéo sympa
monétiser chercher ou en même temps
alors ma deuxième anecdote laquelle est
elle était bien j'étais invité par une
grande marque de cosmétique je viens me
non pour faire un tout petit spectacle
et il y avait le pdg d'eads et lannion
m'avait dit il restera que samedi qui
n'a pas le temps de pointures est
tellement pas eu le temps qu'il a
regardé tout le spectacle est qu'après
comment ça vanne est ensemble et qu'on a
fini tous les deux à quatre heures du
matin dans une cabane dans les arbres
avoir du champagne juste tous les deux
se dépouiller et c'est une très très
très très grosse boîte et c'est vraiment
le cio nawal à se dépouiller samedi à la
maison
cet hiver à dire que c'est qu'on fait
c'est vrai et quelques années
2012 qui pensent 50 dans l'islam il est
bientôt
ben moi aussi mais tu respectes
troisième anecdote j'ai dîné avec les
bleus le lendemain de la coupe du monde
98 était à la même table que du garde
boue laurent blanc non mais même ça non
dans la même salle était à la même table
dans la même ville par minute mais je
n'avais pas marqué par exemple un matin
ils étaient à la table d'à côté
ah oui parce que celle de tous à la
litote on doit tous à la même temps je
devais citer ce qui était la mienne et
madiana anecdote c'est que j'ai donné à
l'orge à l'égard des forces belges il
donnait un cours de cartes magie à
nicolas sarkoy vérité - les lisent
et donc j'ai pas droit d'objection je
pense je l'espère me poser des questions
quoi qu'ils aient déjà ordonné un cours
de cartonnage
ça faisait juste pour ça franchement 1 0
alors en fait ça vient d'une rencontre à
la barre cosy et exim soirée privée pour
la remise de la médaille de chirac aux
harrachis la dette et il ya les sarkozy
quidam et j'ai fait des démonstrations
guitare il avait donc c'est le tout
c'est ce que pour une ethnie cours et
stages possible passage que la question
est donc j'ai dit ok et c'est son
directeur de cabinet qui m'a contactée
après pour presser impôts j'ai donné un
coup ronde et faire plein de cours sur
d'année et afrique et il est tout à fait
réaliste et juste selon lui c'était que
pour nous uniquement au sein du bel20 en
trois mois et une semaine c'est pour ça
que je te lire
et c'était quoi l'autre est enceinte
tina turner
si les bleus d'accord il est capable
alors il avait exactement je vais te
faire le fantasme hamac gauche tout de
suite à ma gauche et du gal ya levé
laurent blanc à ma droite il y avait en
face de moi aux ciseaux et il ya
lessarat zouk est à peu près là et il y
avait adriana karembeu mais pas son mari
qui était à la table avec barthez
[Rires]
pourquoi j'étais là parce que c'était
une soirée de charité point de charité
wef organisé par quartier 2 et que à
l'époque je sortais avec la petite amie
du pdg de capter
je sortais avec je savais que fils
pardon quitter l'aquitaine de faux dans
l'entré jeu d'être au commissariat il
faut que j'avoue un truc et j'ai rien
fait
il y avait du coup ses comptes dans le
conte spectacle ça prend dix idées non
[ __ ] quand je me trompe encore ses
singularités que tu tombes pas parce que
j'oublie c'est terrible des caméras ont
obligé la passion c'est un bon alors
c'est hyper bien préparé je pense
recevoir pour teenagers
alors on arrête la vidéo ici est en
droit de là on va continuer cette
discussion sur la chaîne exact lâché 2 j
étais très amis dont vous retrouver le
lien dans la description ainsi que le
lien de la chaîne de monsieur doc seven
clause est juste là mais qu'il n'y en a
aucun rapport avec cette vidéo
donc on nous donnera les réponses dans
ta vidéo j'ai juste envie aussi de vous
cherchiez par vous même vous pouvez
regarder des anciennes vidéos sur le
mensonge essayé trouvé ça mettre vos
hypothèses dans les commentaires mais
surtout détailler votre hypothèse dit je
pense que c'est un tej
je pense que c'est tel souvenir parce
que ceci parce que cela compte qu'on
puisse essayer d'échanger
peut-être que je casserai des idées
reçues après peut-être même que je
referai une vidéo sur le mensonge en
fonction de vos commentaires
merci beaucoup oubliez pas mettre un
pouce en l'air de vous abonner à la
chaîne cité pas déjà pris parce que j'ai
vu dans mes stable que la moitié d'entre
vous ne sont pas abonnés à la chaîne
cfoot sa clique et c'est gratuit
pour l'instant c'est gratuit profiter
cliquez maintenant parce que youtube
doit peut-être devenir payants et les
abonnements qui seront déjà fait
restaurants halal et l'incident n'a pas
tari
le toi même merci en quoi ça les
schistes merci à thouars s'abonner vous
je renvoie aujourd'hui à troyes où il ya
le mien il ya celui de doc et ilia ii
tient que je viens parce que vous
permettra à ces combats ici je pense
mais n'est pas sûr je crois que cette
fois on va voir qui c'est passé a mis en
attraction d'août soit 33 d'accord mais
il y va en manquer un je ne sais pas ce
que je préfère est gardée bas celui qui
a été le plus d'abonnés